this imaging system is designed to have
vision that works like our eyes do these
little lenses are used to create images
with higher resolution in the center
than at the edges our eyes work the same
way thanks to a region called the fovea
which is rich in light receptors both
eiated electronic centers can see a wide
low resolution view and a narrower
high-resolution view at the same time
instead of one or the other which means
that this camera can capture a scene at
low and high resolution simultaneously
having a wide view with high resolution
in the center preserves detail where
it's needed without sacrificing
processing time in the camera a set of
four compound lenses is 3d printed
directly onto an image sensing chip some
of these lenses see from a wide angle
while others take a narrower view with
higher resolution the information from
each lens is digitally combined to
create associated image with the most
information in the center associated
camera and can do things like helping
self-driving cars make quick judgments
based on visual information at 300
square microns and size with lenses only
a few tens of microns across this camera
is unique in its small size and image
quality there's still room to improve
the manufacturing time and optical
performance of this device but it could
be a boon to engineers who need a device
with quick sharp eagle-eyes
[Music]